une semaine d'utilisation j'ai déjà les
cheveux qui commence à changer j'ai les
cheveux qui commence à être sec les
jours les semaines passent et là je
m'aperçois en fait que je perds en masse
donc en longueur derrière et dès que je
sors ma douche que je me coiffe cd
poignée de cheveux qui commencent à
tomber en fait cindy ne comprend pas
tout de suite ce qui lui arrive ce sont
ses abonnés qui l'alertent
comprend pas top on y voit partout mais
j'ai testé grosse perte de cheveux
démangeaisons savons rien j'ai une
mycose à cause d'une ici paris
super bon quand on les utilise mais
quand on arrête c'est la cata une amie à
cheveux à cause d'eux cindy affirme
qu'elle contacte alors son âge on chez
we event non je me dis mais je suis
vraiment obligé en fait d'utiliser les
produits et là on sort ouvertement ma
chérie si tu veux pas les utiliser tu
fais comme beaucoup le font je m'étais
produit à toi dans les packagings elle
assure que l' agence lui aurait même
envoyé ces photos d'autres femmes à
mettre en ligne à la place d'etienne
c'en est trop pour cindy qui rompt son
contrat quant à ses cheveux elle opte
pour une solution radicale
là bien sûr mises en ligne sur ces
réseaux c'est la seule solution d'en
arriver à me raser la tête donc là c'est
à dire le choc parce que pour une femme
c'est un choc de voir se réaliser la
tête
l'agencé pour moi c'était juste
impensable de rester à travailler avec
eux j'en veux à lagence mais à la marque
à la marque parce que je ne comprends
pas encore à l'heure actuelle comment ce
genre de produit puisse exister être mis
sur les marchés en fait
cindy n'est pas la seule à se plaindre
de cette marque de shampooing sur
internet de nombreux consommateurs
témoigne beaucoup perdent leurs cheveux
photos à l'appui
depuis une procédure judiciaire oppose
la marque et son fournisseur
nous nous sommes procuré ce jugement de
la cour d'appel de paris
on y apprend que la direction de la
répression des fraudes avait analysé ses
shampooings fin 2019 et découvert
plusieurs substances interdites
d'utilisation
c'était avant le partenariat de signes
fin 2020 d'autres analyses ont confirmé
la présence de substances interdites
chez nicky cosmetics est ce pour neuf
produits de la marque
qui est donc le propriétaire de cette
marque
dans les mentions légales du site
surprise il s'agit de la propre agence
d'influenceurs de cindy oui events
dirigé par wesley nakache qui s'est mise
à produire sa propre gamme de
shampooings
il a refusé nos demandes d'interview
nous l'avons appelé il ne sait pas qu'il
est enregistré
pourquoi il y avait des substances
interdites pourquoi ça a continué d'être
vendus c'était pas qu'en 2008 une erreur
de notre de notre fournisseur et la
cosmétologie et des choses qui seront
autorisés et tous les ans
à bercy le phénomène inquiète jusqu'au
sommet de la hiérarchie le ministre de
l'économie en personne s'est fendu d'un
tweet vidéo je voudrais vraiment faire
appel à tous les influenceurs qui ont un
impact considérable sur la décision
d'achat des jeunes prenez vos
responsabilités
le ministère a créé un site dédié pour
signaler les fraudes
[Musique]